when videos like this emerge
Palestinians say it's not the exception
Israeli soldiers dancing with settlers
who entered the Palestinian town of
hawara on Monday night
the only difference is that it was
caught on camera
this was too the security camera footage
shows how Israeli settlers attacked
Palestinians and hawara injuring five
members of the same family including a
two-year-old girl
[Applause]
they were shooting at us with live
ammunition God helped us my wife was
sitting the back behind the driver and
she hugged our daughter to cover her we
could have lost her there was real
danger to our lives
who owns a supermarket
as they were outnumbered and couldn't
push them away
even when the Palestinian cars are the
ones damaged and the attacks took place
against families and children but the
Army treats Palestinians as suspects
Israeli subtler attacks have been on the
rise
Palestinians say the settlers are often
emboldened by the Army which was
deployed to the town south of nablis in
recent weeks
the presence of the Israeli Army doesn't
make Palestinians feel safer many here
tell us the soldiers should do more to
prevent subtler attacks and not force
Palestinians out of their homes in the
guise of keeping them safe
the Israeli forces escorted the news
family out of their home after the
settlers attacked them late in February
the grandmother was with her daughter
and grandchildren in the house when the
settlers set it on fire
the Israeli Army released this picture
of news saying the soldiers were
protecting Palestinians like her in
Shira says she was not protected
the Army only protects the settlers and
not the Palestinians when they saw us
almost getting burnt in the house they
took us out they're here to guard the
settlers
of the eight Israeli settlers arrested
after the attack on Palestinians and
hawara only two are on their house
arrest
this four kilometer stretch of Main Road
in Hawaii has become a flash point in
the growing tension between Palestinians
and Israelis living in illegal
settlements one many here warned could
easily escalate
[Music]
the occupied West Bank